welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of one
division episode five which
spoilers ahead confuses the crap out of
anyone who still thinks about the fox
x-men movies and scares the crap out of
everyone with
baby vision i hate it after re-watching
this episode there are so
many interesting visual details to break
down stuff that does help
explain what exactly is going on with
evan peters pietro and sparky agnes
wanda's history with sword so let's go
back through episode 5
shot by shot for everything you missed
and we actually got to start before the
episode because the first odd detail
comes up in this previously on segment
where is geraldine she's gone she didn't
belong here
this is actually the third version of
this exchange we've seen the first came
in episode three
oh she left honey she had to rush home
but then an altered point of view from
wanda in episode four
oh she left honey she had to rush home
so the words have changed wanda just
being honest she didn't belong here
even now in episode five wanda's hex
continues to warp reality even
outside the parameters of the episode
itself as it streams on disney
plus the fourth wall is breaking down so
much so that character counterparts from
different movie universes are leaking in
in fact throughout this episode you may
notice a red
haze glowing off of the glares and light
sources
inside westview this looks like a
post-production filter in which all the
red
end of the spectrum contained in all
white light was dialed up a bit
just an interesting artistic choice to
show how the scarlet witch's hex
over westview is becoming a bit unstable
babies
billy and tommy won't stop crying why
won't you do what i want
another element in west view outside
wandas control her own children and
pretty terrifying that she's trying to
use
magic to silence them something that she
might do to
say all mutants or whatever else she
wants to say no
more to vision mentions reading them
charles darwin's the descent
of man which is a title about human
evolution
which does reflect the arrival of
mutants to the mcu
and the whole fear that comes with x-men
in the comics right replacing lesser
evolved humans
agnes drops by auntie agnes is here and
i've got a couple of tricks up my sleeve
yeah she refers to herself as auntie
perhaps a callback to auntie a's kitty
litter in the supermarket
in the episode 2 intro which was a clue
then that might point to her being
agatha harkness who does have a black
cat named ebony in the comics
and a few tricks up your sleeve come on
do you want us to trust you or not
visions distrust throws her off in this
interesting way
jimmy take that again yes agnes is
breaking character and she directs this
to wanda directly as if wanda is the
director of this scene
agnes is clearly not fully under wanda's
control
but she plays the part she defers to
wanda as if she's a kind of partner
in order to earn wanda's trust and it
works vision let's
let's let agnes give it a try could
drive a truck through those eyes
but before we continue thank you to
vessy shoes for sponsoring this video
bessie makes these knit sneakers that
are 100 waterproof and snow proof
they're
super breathable so they don't let any
liquid in
but they do let the air move out so no
need to fear wet weather these bad boys
will make you a little kid jumping
through puddles all over again investing
shoes are super
stretchy they fit like a sock they only
weigh 175 grams
which is less than a roll of quarters
and those are way less comfortable to
wear on your feet
they are made with this cool dimetex
material that keeps your feet warm in
cold weather in cool and warm weather
and it is super easy to clean with just
a rinse of water and these are a
sustainably made truly everyday kind of
shoe
the winter is the wet season here in los
angeles and it is great to know that
when i have to leave the house
no matter what is coming out of the sky
my socks will stay nice and dry i'm just
enjoying some nice west view fresh air
with
uh my girl darla here sipping some what
uh i'm glitching uh oh stop that
stop it stop it stop it
stop it oh i don't know what just
happened i totally glitched but hey
even though my shoes are wet fixing
these messy snakes my little piggies are
bone dry
thanks bessie
and this is really the perfect gift for
you and your loved ones especially here
in the midst of the winter and or rainy
season
get them while they still have sizes and
you can thank me later check them out in
the link below and use my code new
rockstars to get 25
off your vessy shoes and of course agnes
mentions ralph again
lavender supposed to have a calming
effect
ralph sprays it on me every night but
there's no tame in this
tiger now agnes calls herself tiger and
notice throughout this episode there's a
little tiger toy
staying in that kitchen maybe agnes eyes
and ears in this house how she's able to
keep tabs on everything and then the
babies go
silent they're empty then where are the
twins
oh for just a moment this kind of evokes
that terrifying scene from robert eggers
the witch
where the sister is left babysitting the
baby playing peek-a-boo until that baby
just
vanishes because it was snatched by the
witch
look folks if there's a witch parallel
to agnes in the show i'm gonna call it
out billy and tommy just
age up five years a nod to the way tv
shows will kind of abruptly age up child
actors between seasons to give them new
speaking roles new identities and then
agnes says this
oh kids
can't control them no matter how hard
you try
later vision does observe that despite
westview being for the children
no other children are in westview so
what's going on other than this all just
being to get wanda to create these two
kids
well i think juandus hex originally
could only control the minds of adults
in west view because adults are more
likely to have
past pain and trauma that can connect
with wanda's pain and trauma meanwhile
westy's children
are innocent pure unburdened by life and
thus those children
may have been immune to the hex able to
run free now this title sequence is
great it pays homage to
380 sitcoms that this episode is based
on family ties with the family portrait
imagery and the duet theme song
growing pains also has a duet theme song
and the amazing progressing age photos
of course full house the sitcom that
launched the careers of elizabeth
olsen's sisters mary kate and ashley and
then that show's opening featured a
family picnic in the same exec shop
where the camera rushes up at the family
running
and this whole set is based on the
family ties set the kitchen has the same
kiss the cook sign just like in family
ties that sofa has a lone blue cushion
which could be not to that maddening
lone blue cushion and growing pains and
the progressing photos of wanda are
actually real photos of elizabeth olsen
but they were edited to place her in
sokovia
notice the sokovian flags behind her in
a second too
that second one being in what i assume
is the ritziest alley in sokovia place
is a [ __ ] all
meanwhile baby vision is a horror show
that i never want to talk about again
[Applause]
this is how billy and tommy celebrate
their birthday with all five number
candles lit
on it since their rapid aging skipped
each of these birthdays they're
celebrating them all at once now notice
how in these holiday photos vision in
costume as a turkey easter bunny santa
each photo shows him getting
progressively
unhappier he clearly no longer wants to
play along with wanda as he does this
episode
so as monica recalls being under mind
control in west view there is this one
little flash of wanda sobbing this
looks like a new shot but that
background is westview her clothes look
like the ones she's wearing in that
footage we've seen where she swoops into
that sword facility
to take visions remains so i'm thinking
this could be right after she brought
vision's corpse and pieces
to westview to try to resurrect him now
monica scans interestingly show a blank
but you can make out the outline of her
neck and shoulders
but her body is coming out overexposed
so monica does have a future as an
avenger she's either going to be named
photon or spectrum
similar powers as captain marvel her
flesh here being composed of pure light
could mean that she already has these
powers
maybe the moment wanda ejected her from
westview now in this briefing the sword
logo shows up on the table it depicts
nine stars eight on each side with one
in the middle i've said before that this
could reflect the nine realms of the
cosmos
we saw in the thor movies that middle
star could be earth aka midgard now the
map also shows this little label near
cape canaveral i'm thinking that could
be where sword hq
is jimmy woo briefs us on wanda's
history born in sokovia in 1989 to irina
and oleg maximoff
both killed during an air raid when
maximoff and her twin brother pietro
were 10. now in the comics wanda and
pietro were raised by
jango and maria maximoff but their real
parentage is to be revealed
as the children of magneto it remains to
be seen if the mcu will embrace this
magneto connection but that air raid was
described by pietro and wanda and age of
ultron remember we're 10 years old
having dinner the four of us and the
first shell hits two floors below and
makes a hole in the floor
and many of us believe that is what that
creepy beeping stark toaster was a
reference to
the mcu in universe news service which
returns here and then hayward cuts off
jimmy as he tries to defend wanda's
reputation
i uh try not to speak ill of people that
allow me
terrorists nice editing making it sound
like hayward's a
terrorist which he totally is he was
using vision parts to make sentient
weapons
subverting vision's will and blaming
wanda of doing the same
and you can see in the footage of
wanda's stealing vision's corpse
vision is broken up into pieces and
sword appears to be experimenting on him
this is likely the robotics nanotech and
ai
projects that hayward was referring to
guy is a dirtbag
further evidence when monica asks when
was this nine days ago
maximoff stormed our facility stole the
vision's body
and resurrected him yeah nine days
interesting timeline
wanda took vision two weeks after end
game which is about
a week before monica returned to sword
hq hayward didn't tell her about any of
this and he probably knew exactly what
he was sending
her to in west view also you probably
heard the sokovia chords
lagos and berlin get mentioned giving us
all the context of wanda's containment
period
starting in civil war which is
explaining why it's so easy for hayward
to paint her as a threat
back at home billy wears red tommy wears
green which
are the colors of wiccan and speed
respectively in the comics it's also the
colors wanda and vision have been
associated with in their wardrobes
sparky the dog sparky is actually vision
synthesis dog
in the tom king vision series very dark
story here so he was originally zeke the
neighbor's dog
a dog who died when he accidentally dug
up the grim reaper's corpse and then
zapped himself on the site you may
remember the grim reaper's helmet was
shown in the floorboards in the episode
two animated intro
perhaps in this episode sparky died when
similarly digging up something in agnes
yard though i gotta say sparky's story
gets even darker in the comics so i'll
come back to this you'll notice vision's
newspaper reads local homemakers
innovating recipes another pointless
headline but on the back an ad for
westview appliances jimmy wu
loves getting coffee monica conceives of
a vehicle to re-enter west view and
setting her up probably to drive that
truck that we saw in the footage
i know an aerospace engineer who'd be up
for this challenge now this
aerospace engineer is not shown yet it's
just monica texting them a lot of people
are saying this could be reed richards
of the fantastic four
based on hayward's past line about
blicked astronauts working for sword
sword very well could be how the mcu
introduces a fantastic four
though in this case i think it would be
a bit of an understated way to introduce
one of the most highly anticipated
marvel hero announcements ever
an off-screen aerospace engineer cool
also john krasinski's already in
wanovision really i think this engineer
is more likely to be the scroll daughter
of talos who monica befriended at the
end of captain marvel
probably one of the extraterrestrial
allies that monaco referred to last
episode maybe someone working with her
and fury as part of sword also if you
look at the spanish subtitles of this
they use a feminine articles for this
engineer so yeah i think it's all pretty
eyes uno player notice how the id
board now includes the mailman
identified so that crosses him
off the list of jimmy wu's missing
witness since that witness wouldn't just
be
another new jersey resident trapped in
west view that they would put on this
board so this tells me that this
witness is still at large they debate
the events of endgame
uh she could have taken out thanos on
her own if he hadn't initiated a blitz
i mean nobody else came close well i'd
argue that captain marvel came close
awkward monica's reaction hints at some
bad blood between her and carol danvers
it reminds me of that interesting
reaction from nick fury well technically
the skrull talos and spider-man far from
home
captain marvel don't invoke her name man
people are hating on carol
taylor's fury monica they all appear to
be on the same pro
scroll side coming out of captain marvel
and that space station fury was on at
the end of far from home might be part
of sword
so did captain marvel do them dirty did
she betray them did she fail to save
maria rambo and they all hold it against
her
monika so pissed off that she pulls a
peggy carter in terms of terrible indoor
firearm safety then this interesting
scene at work vision awakens
norm now weirdly we did see this written
down as a note on avalash's profile memo
last episode before vision awakened him
and i know you could say
time dilation inside west view but no it
could not have happened until after
monaco was ejected from the 70s era in
episode 3
4 to set up this 80s era with vision and
norm in the computer scene so what's the
story here a continuity here i just
think a lot of these scenes were
shot around the same time and out of
chronological order and props like this
memo were made without the expectation
that
psychopaths like us would be able to
read it ultimately i think this is an
example of them re-editing some episodes
maybe so casual viewers would get more
context
earlier but also note that abulash never
says that wanda is doing this
just her the her of this mystery doesn't
have to be wanda it could be
agnes in his head billy train sparky
sparky sit
good dog another sitcom reference here
to the ubu productions bumper that would
play after the credits of episodes of
family ties
[ __ ] ubu [ __ ] good dog also notice how
billy puts a treat to
his temple as he trains a dog to speak
as the future wiccan he
will share his mother's telepathic
abilities so maybe he's so good at
training this dog because a kid
is telepathic and can mind control
animals then after the attempted drone
strike wanda's pissed she breaches the
perimeter and issues this stern warning
stay out of my home you don't bother me
i won't bother you now you may have
noticed a bit of wanda sakovian accent
making its way back in there she's
reconnecting with the more villainous
roots that she had in asia voltron and
she redirects the sword guns at hayward
though notice
none of them are aimed at monica showing
wanda might still see monica as a
potential ally it's really just hayward
and his
exploitation of visions remains that
pissed off wanda so much
also turning a bunch of guns like that
yeah totally a magneto move
we saw him do that in the first x-men
movie i am hoping that this big mystery
cameo that the actors keep
teasing is gonna be ian mckellen magneto
the magnus of this house of m adaptation
as wanda and pietro's true father and if
so that apple ain't falling far from the
tree
wanda turns the border wall a
threatening red and we got to commercial
this time for
lagos brand paper towels for when you
make a mess he didn't mean to
just like the other commercials we've
seen this is the latest example to echo
wanda's past trauma when she
accidentally threw crossbones suicide
bomb explosion into a building killing a
lot of innocent people
that was the final straw event that led
to the sokovia accords in the civil war
conflict but listen closely as this
commercial
ends but when you make a mess you didn't
mean to
yeah despite the paper towels this blood
red mess
continues to slowly drip the bloody mess
wanda made haunting her with guilt
sparky runs off goes missing and the
mailman says your mom won't let him get
far
ma'am yeah just like dr nielsen the
mailman is hinting that it is hard to
get too far away from this queen bee
and they find him and it's very sad i
don't know how many
leaves he ate i didn't find him until it
was too late
yeah she [ __ ] killed that dog and
they just caught her trying to bury him
so looping back to that tom king vision
run trigger warning for animal abuse
here
virginia beats sparky the dog to death
and then among the dog's remains
virginia sees that the dog had eaten
a plant called the wondergore everblood
and she eats another petal of that and
she's able to see the future as she
cries
that plant grows in the yard of agatha
harkness
so yeah i think sparky either dug up or
saw something that he should not have at
agnes property maybe he saw ralph and
like the wicked witch of the west miss
gulch she put
a hit on wanda's toto got her little dog
too
because notice how agnes reacts when
tommy asks wanda to resurrect sparky
you can do that yeah agnes might feel
threatened that wanda might resurrect
this witness or that billy could use his
telepathic speak command to
learn what agnes was trying to hide from
them or agnes knows full well that wanda
can resurrect the dead
like these two witches already did it
with vision and she's just doing a very
good job playing dumb
wanda pretty hypocritically tells her
kids that she can't reverse death
despite doing a provision forbidding
them to age past 10 which is interesting
because it's the same age she and pietro
were when they lost their innocence and
their parents and their lives changed
forever
vision has to bury sparky outside and he
washes his hands this is in the same
sink that he
and we all first saw sparky get in a
bath to be clean and pure enough to join
this family there's probably a little
doggy here still in that drain
wanda tries to use the credits to evade
the argument here
a crazy meta moment remind me a lot of
too many cooks
kiss the cook no too many cooks and
again all these names are people who
work for marvel studios jimmy gad works
in post-production
jeremy simpson we talked about him
before he's a storyboard artist leanne
patrick post-production brandy hawkins
an
extra casting assistant scott mcfate the
effects team
crawford norman production annel
onyekuere
i'm sorry i mispronounced that music
editor lacey hudson works in props andra
edwards vfx miriam mccoob works in
production
patrick heskew works in vfx and courtney
young is marvel dialect
coach and you can thank her for want to
sakovian accent coming back you don't
bother me
i won't bother you then after their
fight they are greeted by
wanda's long-lost brother pietro played
not by aaron taylor johnson from age of
ultron but
by evan peters you didn't see that
coming the quicksilver from the fox
x-men movies
long-lost bro get to squeeze his
stinking sister to death or what yeah
peters is really enjoying this he's
playing up the cool uncle like uncle
jesse from full house
have mercy darcy's recasting comment is
an odd of the way sitcoms movies will
just do this they'll recast actors
without much explanation
aunt viv rhodey bruce banner now when
peters was rumored to play a role in
wanovision
months ago many of our assumptions were
that it would be some alt universe
quicksilver in that we were looking at a
multiverse crossover now that disney
owns the rights to the x-men
this westview anomaly may be pulling
cultural references from other
pop culture as a way of tying in other
dimensions of the multiverse and that
one of those could just
be the fox x-men franchise and if that's
the logic that's gonna open the door to
a lot of other cameos from that universe
think about it ian mckellen magneto
patrick stewart professor x
anyone who's in those movies ryan
reynolds deadpool but this could be
something else it could be looking at
the mystery force
inside westview jimmy wu's missing
witness with brainwashing capabilities
agnes husband ralph whoever first
trapped wanda in this
that entity could be using a quicksilver
disguise
to try to keep wanda happy when vision
is no longer able to do so
yes mephisto in an evan peters mask why
then peters though
well this sitcom decade is in the 80s
and aaron taylor johnson's quicksilver
wasn't born until 1989 they just told us
so they needed to pluck a quicksilver
from the multiverse who was active
during the 80s
and if you think about it like the
episodes of wandavision the later fox
x-men movies jumped ahead
decade by decade first class was in the
1960s
days of future past was in the 1970s
x-men apocalypse was in the 1980s dark
phoenix was in the 1990s and since evan
peters quicksilver was moonwalking in
the 80s in x-men apocalypse he now
does kind of fit in this timeline at
least within the anomaly
now pietro's return could be something
as simple as a sweet gesture from the
boys trying to cheer up mommy with a
long-lost brother that she said that she
missed but i don't trust this guy he
talks about squeezing his sister to
death he calls vision a popsicle which
feels like a slur the way he says it but
guys guys guys the creepiest detail is
the mirror behind wanda
look at the second pietro comes in
through the door it's really hard to see
but this mirror looks
distorted warped it almost looks like
pietro's hand is red
and it might be crazy but there's some
weird blur
in this almost as if there's some thin
gray
arm reaching out toward pietro beckoning
him
into this house what is this reflecting
there's nothing there but there's
something in the mirror look whatever
pietro's origin folks there's enough
in this to see him as a threat to wanda
some kind of trick
to give her the one more thing she could
possibly want but like everything else
in west view
it ain't gonna last ah yes i am wearing
our latest obsession shirt an unusual
couple limited supply still available at
our merch store near rockstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram eddie avos
following rockstars subscribe to new
rockstars on youtube for breakdowns of
all your one division confusion
thank you for watching
[Music]
you